terror krieg zerstörung mit dem aufstieg
des sogenannten islamischen staates
beginnt 2014 für den norden syriens eine
zeit des schreckens meine sechsjährige
tochter hat enthauptete menschen gesehen
tausende verlieren ihr leben unter
großen verlusten gelingt des kurdischen
widerstands milizen das terror kalifat
zu besiegen
dort sind ihre gräber nur mit fotos der
toten ohne namen
geblieben ist ein vom krieg gezeichnete
stan abtes land wir akzeptieren das
nicht mehr es reicht das ist doch kein
leben und menschen mit ungewissem
schicksal eine region im schwebezustand
die menschen haben angst vor einem
nächsten krieg wer wird das gebiet
morgen kontrollieren bleiben die kunden
kommen us truppen zurück
meiner meinung nach hängt die sicherheit
der region von der anwesenheit der
amerikaner
wenn alle weggehen werden wir nichts
erreichen das ist unser land wir sollten
wir es denn überlassen
dieser film dokumentiert die zeit in der
die kurden in nordsyrien noch an eine
selbstbestimmte und friedliche zukunft
glauben doch seit dem einmarsch
türkischer truppen im oktober 2009 10
ist alles wieder fraglich
die kurven gelten als das größte
staatenlose volk der welt ihr
historisches siedlungsgebiet verteilt
sich heute auf vier staaten die türkei
den iran irak und syrien
wir haben keine freunde außerdem bergen
lautet ein kurdisches sprichwort und
schon immer waren die kurden spielball
der politik im syrischen bürgerkrieg
verhalten sie sich lange zeit neutral
doch als sie es kämpfer einen drauf nach
dem anderen erobern
greifen sie zu den waffen mit
unterstützung us amerikanischer truppen
besiegen sie die islamisten
am fluss tigris beginnt das gebiet der
syrischen kurden dass sie roger warnen
hier beginnt unsere reise die felder
sind abgeerntet branche war es seit
jeher die kornkammer der region
fruchtbarer boden auf dem die menschen
weizen baumwolle und gemüse anbauen und
kostbarer boden denn es gibt große
erdölvorkommen von größeren
kriegshandlungen bleibt der landstrich
an der grenze zur türkei und dem irak
verschont dennoch sind die kriegsfolgen
überall zu spüren
etwa in mosel an das kleine dorf steht
stellvertretend für unzählige orte in
nordsyrien zu beginn des krieges
versuchen sowohl syriens diktator assad
wie auch die kurdische selbstverwaltung
die jungen männer des dorfes zum
militärdienst zu verpflichten
viele von ihnen fliehen nach europa es
sollte nicht der einzige
schicksalsschlag bleiben im dorf das von
der landwirtschaft lebt bleibt
irgendwann das wasser weg früher lebten
hier im dorf viele junge leute manchmal
saßen 20 zusammen und spielten karten
ganze turnier um süßigkeiten oder
truthähne haben wir gemacht jetzt sind
es nur noch drei oder vier wird jemand
krank sind wir zu wenige um karten zu
spielen
hier ist der dorfbrunnen
er hat uns früher unser wasser gegeben
jetzt ist er ausgetrocknet wir haben ihn
abgedeckt damit die kinder beim spielen
nicht hineinfallen
aber eigentlich ist das gar nicht nötig
denn es gibt hier fast keine kinder mehr
alle dorfbewohner haben das wasser mit
einem schlauch hoch geholt
wir haben es als trinkwasser genutzt im
haushalt und um unsere gärten damit zu
bewässern
[Musik]
hier stand früher die dorfschule nur
noch der fußabstreifer ist übrig an dem
wir den dreck von unseren schuhen
gekratzt haben wir lernten früher
hunderte kinder viele wurden ingenieure
anwälte oder ärzte entweder sind sie
jetzt in europa oder leben mit ihren
familien in städten wie kam er schlug
dem iran oder hier in der nähe in der
weg der terror des hat dafür gesorgt
dass sich viele hier von der religion
abgewandt haben
wenn ein muslim einen menschen auf den
boden zwingt und ihn enthauptet so etwas
haben wir noch nie gesehen
wer macht so was sie haben gott ist groß
gerufen und dabei menschen kinder
enthauptet sie haben kinder ermordet so
etwas gab es hier nie zuvor nicht in der
kurdischen gesellschaft und nicht in der
islamischen gesellschaft
morsal an ist kein einzelfall
wer eine bessere zukunft sucht derzeit
weg von hier
[Musik]
weiterfahrt nach kamishli so heißt die
stadt auf arabisch die kurden sagen kann
ich schon
sie ist die größte stadt der region
der weizen in den riesigen getreidesilos
ernährt die circa 200.000 einwohner
begründet wird die stadt vor fast 100
jahren von aramäern überlebenden des
völkermordes an den syrischen christen
im osmanischen reich als der islamische
staat das land mit krieg überziehen mit
kamishli erneut zum zufluchtsort für
tausende flüchtlinge in der stadt leben
aramäer kurden araber und arminia
politisch ist die stadt geteilt die eine
hälfte wird von der kurdischen
selbstverwaltung kontrolliert die andere
vom assad-regime
manchmal kommt es zu konfrontationen
doch meist herrscht waffenstillstand
zwischen den beiden lagern
in den vom regime beherrschten vierteln
finden sich überall bilder von hafez
al-assad und seinem sohn dem jetzigen
diktator baschar hier zu filmen ist
riskant es drohen lange haftstrafen
wegen spionage
kamishli ist traditionell eines der
zentren des christentums in syrien wie
lange wohl noch fragt sich auch china
christin und menschenrechtsaktivistin
die christen um die muslime leben hier
friedlich nebeneinander
es gibt keine probleme doch wir wissen
dass es jederzeit knallen könnte im
allgemeinen lebt jeder für sich
man kann sagen dass die hälfte der
syrischen christen seit beginn des
bürgerkrieges 2011 das land verlassen
hat
auch ich und meine familie hätten gehen
können aber ich wollte nicht wir sind
nicht weggegangen wie sind kinder dieses
landes was hier passiert betrifft auch
uns
es gibt so viel zu tun wenn wir alle das
land verlassen und weggehen werden wir
nicht das erreichen wofür wir auf die
straße gegangen sind
außerdem ist das unser land wem sollen
wir es überlassen
viele die hier geblieben sind sind aus
überzeugung geblieben
und wenn wir weggehen müssen wir
woanders bei null anfangen wozu wir
bleiben und tun was in unserer macht
steht für uns und den nächsten
generation
viele gebiete sind zwar vom eis befreit
trotzdem haben die menschen große angst
[Musik]
die situation in nordost syrien ist
anders als in anderen gebieten syriens
doch die frage bleibt wird es einen
neuen krieg geben oder bleibt alles
ruhig
[Musik]
deswegen fliehen auch wieder mehr
menschen
viele haben angst vor der zukunft in den
letzten 7 jahren haben wir großes elend
erlebt deswegen verlassen die menschen
das land
aber ich bin immer noch hier und werde
hier bleiben solange ich kann auch lava
red kennt dieses gefühl die junge kurdin
arbeitet als reporterin für den
nachrichtensender kurdistan 24 der seit
2005 10 die selbstbestimmung der kurden
thematisiert lava stammt aus kamishli
die stadt ist ihr zuhause
unser größtes problem ist nicht zu
wissen was als nächstes passieren wird
wenn wir ins bett gehen fragen wir uns
wer hier morgen herrschen wird bleiben
die kurden oder gehen sie kommt das
assad regime zurück die anwesenheit der
amerikaner sorgt für sicherheit
wenn sie sich zurückziehen wird das
regime in damaskus erst die provinzen
daraa und edel kontrollieren und danach
auch die kurdischen gebiete weil sie zu
syrien gehören die menschen leben mit
dieser großen unsicherheit zurzeit sind
wir glücklich und leben in frieden die
normalität kehrt zurück keine
schießereien keine explosionen im
vergleich zu anderen teilen syriens ist
es in orange war ganz in atem
es gibt arbeit der wiederaufbau läuft
aber die innere unruhe bleibt bis wir
wissen wie es weitergehen
die kurden träumen von einem staat
kurdistan ob diese jemals wirklichkeit
wird weiß niemand
kanisch leben für viele jahre das
zentrum der kurdischen selbstverwaltung
in nordsyrien mittlerweile hat auch die
stadt hassake an bedeutung gewonnen
lava will ihren beitrag zur kurdischen
sache leisten
und da ist noch etwas mit beginn des
bürgerkrieges 2011 hat sich vieles
geändert
aber ich will nicht weg ich bin eine von
denen die sagen wir werden kam ich so
nicht verlassen
wir bleiben es fehlt so schwer das land
zu verlassen in dem man seine kindheit
verbrachte wo man aufgewachsen ist
vor einem jahr war ich einfach nur müde
und habe mit dem gedanken gespielt
rauscher war zu verlassen
aber eine sache hält mich auch wenn all
meine freunde längst wechseln morgens
wenn ich ein paar straßen zu fuß zur
arbeit gehen bevor ich ein taxi nehmen
rieche ich den duft von frisch
gebackenem brot mittlerweile hat sich
viel verändert
die gebäude sind andere viele kurden
sind weggezogen araber sind als
flüchtlinge hergezogen und das ist okay
aber es ist eben doch eine veränderung
der duft des brotes gibt mir ein gefühl
als habe sich nichts in kam ich nur
verändert und als ging das leben weiter
wie früher
dieser produkt hält mich
[Musik]
wenige kilometer von kamishli entfernt
erscheint uns der duft von brot nur noch
eine ferne erinnerung hier steigen jeden
abend gigantische rauchsäulen in den
himmel
rückstände die bei der herstellung von
diesel anfallen werden bei
sonnenuntergang von den raffinerie
arbeitern abgefackelt
[Musik]
der qualm verpestet die atemluft
die kinder von gary spielen dennoch
draußen im krieg ist umweltschutz kein
thema hört das schießen und bomben auf
mit der rauch zum killer nummer eins als
sie unsere kamera sehen kommen die
bewohner des dorfes zusammen
sie wollen uns von ihrem schicksal
erzählen ich bin herber ich arbeite als
krankenschwester im schutzgebiet und
wohnen hier in gelb die kinder kommen
jeden tag zu mir und ich gebe ihnen
spritzen
alle kinder haben lungenentzündungen und
allergien und probleme mit die
nasenschleimhäute die älteren menschen
haben atemwegserkrankungen und bekommen
krebs es ist ein langsames sterben
die neugeborenen kommen hier mit
fehlbildungen zur welt
sogar die tiere leiden unter diesem rat
ihr er war eben bei mir und hat eine
spritze bekommen
der andere war gestern bei mir alle
kinder haben lungenentzündungen wir die
dorfbewohner von gerd-peter sind
machtlos besonders die armen unter uns
aber die besitzer der raffinerien
interessiert das gar nicht wir machen
uns sorgen um unsere kinder
viele haben das land schon verlassen wir
sind geblieben und diese kinder sind die
zukunft von rosa war mein sohn ist heute
aufgestanden und ihm war übel wegen des
geruchs beschwert man sich heißt es halt
den mund
alle meine kinder haben allergien die
krankenschwester kann euch sagen wie
viele spritzen unserer kinder bekommen
auch meine lunge ist geradezu
die ölindustrie ist ein entscheidender
wirtschaftsfaktor in den kurdischen
gebieten syriens und wirft eine menge
geld ab es dürfte kein zufall sein dass
die amerikaner ausgerechnet in diesem
gebiet syriens auch mit bodentruppen in
den krieg eingriffen haben und noch
immer vor ort sind der schutz der
ölvorkommen steht weit oben auf
washingtons agenda die vorsintflutlichen
fördermethoden vergiften nicht nur die
bevölkerung sondern auch ganz extrem die
umwelt überall sichert öl ins
grundwasser
[Musik]
der reichtum branche was ist für viele
menschen zum fluch geworden
im örtlichen gesundheitszentrum
berichtet man uns wie gefährlich die
arbeit in den veralteten förderanlagen
ist in den raffinerien kommt es
regelmäßig zu explosionen
die arbeiter kommen dann mit
verbrennungen zu uns diese diesel
gewinnung verursacht viele probleme und
krankheit
unsere weite reise führt entlang der
legendären bagdad bahn an ihrem bau vor
mehr als 100 jahren quer durch das
osmanische reich sind auch deutsche
firmen beteiligt nach dem ersten
weltkrieg wird die bahnstrecke zur
offiziellen grenzlinie zwischen den
beiden neuen staaten syrien und türkei
das siedlungsgebiet vieler kunden wird
dadurch geteilt manchmal verläuft die
grenze mitten durch ortschaften die
kurdische bevölkerung führt zu
minderheiten in beiden staaten
nächste station die grenzstadt ein al
arab die im westen unter ihrem
kurdischen namen traurige berühmtheit
erlangt hat qurbani 2014 beginnt die
türkei mit hilfe von finanzmitteln der
europäischen union damit eine drei meter
hohe mauer zum nachbarstaat syrien zu
errichten
sie ist teil des sogenannten flüchtlings
deals zwischen europa und ankara
illegale grenzübertritte von
flüchtlingen sollen so verhindert werden
kinder spielen wenige meter entfernt sie
bauen ihre eigenen mauern
was macht ihr
spielt ihr auch da hinten bei der echten
mauer warum nicht ist das gefährlich
schießen die ja
[Musik]
die stadt ist wie viele andere in syrien
zu großen teilen zerstört
[Musik]
dennoch ist qurbani für die menschen
hier mehr als eine stadt
sie ist symbol für den widerstand als
die terroristen des islamischen staates
2014 das halbe land erobern wüten sie
auch hier die kurdischen
selbstverteidigungs einheiten der gpg
kämpfen um jedes viertel jede straße
jedes haus der kampf scheint fast
verloren als sich die usa entschließen
den kurden zu helfen
unterstützt durch die luftschläge der
amerikaner gelingt es den es zu besiegen
und die stadt zu befreien
[Musik]
heute ist das leben in die stadt
zurückgekehrt doch zurückgelassene
waffen erinnern überall an den i s bei
der befreiung der stadt wirken auch
viele frauen mit wie die gbg
kommandeuren arikan im laufe eines
gefechts wird sie von iris kämpfern
eingekesselt irgendwann geht ihr die
munition aus doch statt sich zu ergeben
sprengte sich in die luft und reißt
etliche ihrer feinde mit in den tod
dafür verehren sie die menschen in kuba
nie als märtyrerin
ihre statue im zentrum der stadt ist ein
beliebtes foto motiv
der umgang der syrischen kurden mit
ihren gefallenen zeigt wie
unterschiedlich die sicht auf diesen
krieg ist die volks verteidigungs
einheiten der epg gelten als eng mit der
verbotenen arbeiterpartei pkk verbunden
die die türkei und der westen als
terrorgruppe einstuften
für die bevölkerung qurbanis ist amir
khan eine heldin für die türkische
regierung eine terroristin werner roger
war kommt um einfache wahrheiten zu
finden wird enttäuscht die realität ist
auch hier komplexer als das simple gut
gegen böse
die freiheit qurbanis und seine bewohner
ist teuer erkauft abertausende haben mit
ihrem leben bezahlt sie sind auf dem
neuen märtyrer friedhof der stadt
begraben
nicht nur kurden kämpfen in den reihen
der volks verteidigungs einheiten gegen
die islamisten einige europäer und
amerikaner unterstützen sie als
freiwillige im reservat zu verteidigen
[Musik]
für die kurden haben die frauen und
männer die hier begraben sind beinahe
heiligen status sie sind märtyrer
[Musik]
der bruder dieses mannes feld 2014
mein bruder war sehr fromm
er hatte seinen koran dabei als er
gestorben ist
er hat regelmäßig gebetet hat sogar an
der front nach wasser für die rituelle
waschung gefragt seine freunde haben ihm
gesagt du bist ein gpg kämpfer wir sind
im krieg und du fragst nach wasser zum
waschen seine wäsche hat er selbst
gewaschen
er war für gleichberechtigung und wollte
dass wir konnten zeigen dass wir anders
sind
meine mutter ist mit mir hier
sie besucht das grab einmal in der woche
mein bruder hat immer gesagt der mensch
an sich sehr gut und dass wir uns
gegenseitig helfen müssen und gutes tun
sollen und andere menschen nicht
verraten
er war vom guten im menschen überzeugt
was sagen die religion bei den juden
christen und den muslimen heißt es alle
menschen sind gleich die guten menschen
werden am ende siegen und wenn nicht in
diesem leben dann im nächsten
dank dieser märtyrer können wir jetzt
hier leben
ich bin immer noch davon überzeugt dass
sie für eine gute sache gestorben sind
mein sohn kämpft auch mit ihr liegt mein
bruder da hinten drei meiner cousins
sechs meine angehörigen sind tot
wir wollen ihren weg weiterführen
ich habe zu meinem bruder gesagt er
könne menschen mehr helfen wenn er etwas
anderes tue und nicht kämpfe als
studierter computerexperte hätte er auf
andere weise helfen können
aber er sagte zu mir dass menschen aus
der ganzen welt herkommen um für kuranyi
zu kämpfen sollen die menschen sagen
dass während die fremden qurbani befreit
haben kann ihm auf einem bürostuhl saß
niemals ich werde mit kämpfen sagte er
er war teil einer kampfeinheit die sich
weigerte sich zurückzuziehen und ist
gefallen
wir nähern uns racker der ehemaligen
hauptstadt des von hier aus herrscht ab
der selbsternannte khalifa bakr al
baghdadi über ein gebiet von den
ausmaßen großbritanniens heute existiert
er es nur noch im untergrund als
terrorgruppe
dieser erfolg hat viele tote gefordert
hauptsächlich unter kurden mehr als
11.000 kämpfer der volks verteidigungs
einheiten gpg fallen weitere 21.000
werden zum teil schwer verwundet ein
riesenproblem in einer region in der
medizinische versorgung kaum vorhanden
ist
wie viele es kämpfer sterben lässt sich
nur schwer schätzen
kurdische quellen sprechen von mehreren
zehntausend toten bei den kämpfen in
nordsyrien kommen mehrere tausend
zivilisten um
allein in racker sind es über 1600
hunderttausende kurden fliehen aus ihrer
heimat
es wird jahrzehnte dauern bis diese
wunden verheilt sind etwa 100.000
menschen meist syrische araber sind
mittlerweile nach hacker zurückgekehrt
diejenigen deren häuser vermietet oder
zerstört wurden campieren in zeltlagern
es fehlt an nahrung und medikamenten
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
im winter sterben kinder an unterkühlung
die schlacht um racker ist lange vorbei
das sterben geht weiter 80 prozent der
stadt sind zerstört große teile immer
noch verdient das macht den wiederaufbau
rakers äußerst schwierig nach wie vor
gibt es schläferzellen des mehrmals die
woche kommt es zu bomben anschlägen und
gefechten mit sicherheitskräften
das risiko erschossen oder entführt zu
werden ist allgegenwärtig
an keinem ort halten wir uns deshalb
länger als 15 minuten auf auch ja nicht
die aufmerksamkeit auf uns zu ziehen
[Musik]
wir treffen eine gruppe von männern am
kreisverkehr am uhrenturm tauschen sie
die letzten neuigkeiten aus er ist heute
ist wieder eine autobombe hochgegangen
die haben sie an einem auto der stf
platziert und sie ist explodiert die
menschen verkaufen das benzin um zu
überleben
gestern wurden zwei männer von einem
motorradfahrer erschossen
also werden hier jeden tag menschen
ermordet entweder explodiert jeden tag
eine granate oder eine autobombe
da hinten lag gestern auch schon wieder
eine leiche im park im park ja im park
in catania wurden zwei personen getötet
wie arbeitet die verwaltung der stadtrat
ist gut aber es gibt keine lebensmittel
helfen gar nichts was ist daran gut
reparaturen kanalisation das alles läuft
sie arbeiten dran aber für die menschen
tun sie nichts für die leute ist es
schwer man kann sich kaum etwas leisten
viele menschen hungern können sich kein
essen kaufen
am markt sammeln sie tomaten und gurken
aus dem müll
du solltest zur müllkippe gehen und
sehen wie die frauen dort reste zusammen
glauben mir geht es gut und andere haben
nicht mal das geld für brot wie war das
hier vor zwei jahren als der jetzt hier
war ja wie war es unter dem er das leben
war gut aber die bevölkerung wurde total
kontrolliert und litt unter dem embargo
offiziell ist der es zwar besiegt doch
seine ideologie spuckt weiter in den
köpfen von sympathisanten und
kollaborateuren kaum vorzustellen wenn
man sich die gräueltaten der selbst
ernannten gotteskrieger vor augen führt
grausame hinrichtung des videos wie
dieses wurden zum markenzeichen der
terror miliz hier sind drei männer als
spione angeklagt
sie gehören zu den ersten opfern der
terroristen in racker
in der nähe des ehemaligen
hinrichtungsstätte berichtet ein mann
von damals er will unerkannt bleiben aus
angst unter dem es wurden viele menschen
vor unseren augen enthauptet hände
wurden abgeschnitten
sogar kinder haben so etwas gesehen und
sind hierüber enthauptete leichen
gestolpert meine sechsjährige tochter
hat das gesehen da hinten wo die uhr ist
und an allen wichtigen plätzen und
kreisverkehren da wo viele menschen sind
wurden ihre bestrafungen durchgeführt
damit möglichst viele das sehen und
angst bekommen der es hat unser leben
völlig verändert
für jede kleinigkeit wurdest du hart
bestraft sie bestimmten welche kleidung
getragen durftest wieder ein bad
aussehen sollte es gab keine freiheit
mehr nicht die geringste du warst kein
freier mensch mehr
wir haben sogar vorgeschrieben welche
rosen antrag für die frauen war es noch
schlimmer und ständig gab es neue regeln
am anfang mussten sie ein schwarzes
kopftuch tragen dann irgendwann gitter
vor den augen dann noch handschuhe
am ende war gar nichts mehr von der frau
zu sehen
wenn der muezzin zum gebet rief mussten
die läden geschlossen sein wie es
kämpfer patrouillierten durch die
straßen
man musste in der moschee sein oder zu
hause oder an orten wo gemeinsam gebetet
wurde während des gebetes herrschte
ausgangssperre
man sagt keine menschen auf der straße
alle hatten angst vor dem s und angst
vor den bombardierungen assad hat nicht
den es bombardiert sondern die
zivilbevölkerung und noch schlimmer
waren die russischen angriffe ob ihr das
jetzt hören wollt oder nicht
jetzt sagen sie sie seien als befreier
gekommen
aber diese ganze zerstörung es hat sich
nicht gelohnt so große teile der stadt
liegen in schutt und asche
aber war es das wert und die verlierer
sind wie immer die zivilisten
juni 2017 der kampf um racker ist
entbrannt
in den häusern der stadt verschanzen
sich tausende terroristen
es beginnt mit luftschlägen
den kampfflugzeugen der anti es
koalition hat die terror miliz nicht
viel entgegenzusetzen
es gibt berichte nach denen die usa auf
weißem phosphor einsetzen als waffe
gegen menschen ist diese munition
international geächtet sie verbrennt mit
mehr als 1300 grad celsius der e s
missbraucht die einwohner als
menschliche schutzschilde viele
zivilisten sterben in seinen
propagandavideos schlachtet der es das
leid der bevölkerung aus als beweis für
die grausamkeit des feindes die
islamisten setzen rollende bomben ein
gepanzerte autos gesteuert von
selbstmordattentätern
auch handelsübliche drohnen werden zu
terror waffen umgebaut
am ende steht ein verlustreicher
häuserkampf beide seiten filmen die
kämpfer und veröffentlichen das material
im internet
der krieg wird somit auch in den
sozialen medien ausgetragen
videos des muten dabei oftmals wie
egoshooter spiele an
aber auch die epg milizen wissen ihre
kämpferinnen in szene zu setzen
die schlacht dauert insgesamt vier
monate auf unserer rückfahrt richtung
irakische grenze wirken erlebnisse und
bilder unserer zweiwöchigen reise lief
roger war nach was geht in den menschen
vor die sich dem nissan schlossen
antworten suchen wir im campos in der
nähe von der dik mehr als 180 junge
frauen aus deutschland lebten bei midas
nun hoffen sie auf rückkehr
auch wenn ihnen der prozess droht unsere
gesprächspartnerin eine konvertitin
lebte in racker sie saß bereits in einem
kurdischen gefängnis zu einer
isolationszelle über anderthalb monaten
das war schon sehr übel
also ich war der in dem ersten platz wo
ich wahr was nur dunkel und ich konnte
zwei mal am tag auf toilette in dem
zweiten platz was nur hell
also da war 24 stunden das licht an also
die gefängnisse und schrecklich also
dagegen ist das gefängnis in deutschland
sehr gut und dann jedes camp gekommen
der wende kam dann noch mal hierher und
das war es auch also mittlerweile wissen
wir gar nichts
wir haben keine neuigkeiten wir wissen
gar nicht mehr was jetzt mit uns
passiert auf wir zurückkommen und es ist
er hat hier jeder hat wurden auch schon
frauen vergewaltigt also damit dass
nicht die runde gemacht wurden sie in
andere camps gebracht und es schon
sind kinder hier gestorben bei an
mangelnder ernährung anfangen den
medizinischen versorgung der iss
ermordete und versklavte insbesondere
angehörige der schiitischen minderheit
was würde sie einer solchen jesiden
sagen was ich ihr sagen würde dass uns
hier auch sehr viele sachen passiert
sind und ich zum beispiel einen fehler
gemacht habe also nur in einen staat zu
ziehen um dort zu leben
das macht mich ja nicht schuldig für
irgendetwas keiner von uns hat sich
irgendwie strafbar gemacht noch
irgendwelche sachen gemacht die jemanden
schaden würden also wenn wir zurückgehen
wir sind niemand da jemanden schadet im
gegenteil ich glaube uns wurde sehr viel
schaden zugefügt das werdet ihr
vielleicht noch sehen wenn wir
zurückkommen und das jedoch erfahren
wird es mit uns alles gemacht wurde und
was dachte sie über die grausamen
hinrichtungen die überall in rackert zu
sehen waren
[Musik]
also ich muss auch ehrlich sein es ist
gut dass ich nicht gesehen habe ich kann
so was nicht sehen deswegen auch nicht
gar nicht ich war die meiste zeit zu
hause also 90 prozent luft bist du mich
frage wie menschen haben die gesagt auf
die straße ich bin mit meinem mann ganz
normal rausgegangen
also mein mann ist überhaupt nicht so
dass mich immer mitgenommen motorrad
sind immer sheikh auch trinken gegangen
oder wir sind spazieren gegangen also
ich war immer mit meinem mann draußen
die einzigen schlimmen dinge die sie
gesehen haben will
waren die bomben der amerikaner kann ich
gar nicht beschreiben
ich habe die kinder körper gesehen
abgetrennte köpfe ich hab' ich habe
wirklich alles gesehen und das war
wirklich sich also ich glaube das ist
eine riesen trauma was ich auch glaube
ich niemand leben vergessen werde
ich habe kinder unter trümmern gehört
der noch geschrien und es gab einfach
keine möglichkeiten mehr herauszuholen
ja ich möchte gerne meine familie und
ich möchte wieder ein ganz normales
geregeltes leben haben wieder macht mein
fehler und ich hoffe jeder von uns
bekommt eine zweite chance dass wir nach
hause können eine ägypterin die
ebenfalls als frau eines kämpfers in
racker lebte berichtet uns anderes
ja wenn wir auf der straße waren haben
wir all das gesehen enthauptungen hände
abschlag
es war immer voll mit zuschauern die
situation hier im camp ist gut aber es
bleibt eben ein provisorisches
flüchtlingslager es ist schwer hier sein
ganzes leben mit den kindern zu
verbringen
ich hoffe dass wir ein land finden das
uns als flüchtlinge aufnimmt wie und wo
die frauen heute leben wissen wir nicht
nach kurdischen und us-amerikanischen
schätzungen warten etwa 2000
ausländische kämpfer und ihre familien
darauf dass ihre heimatländer sie
zurücknehmen und die anderen menschen
die wir sprechen konnten was ist aus
ihnen geworden
die journalistin lava ist unfreiwillig
zur kriegsreporterin geworden
hier berichtet sie von einem
zusammenstoß amerikanischer syrischer
und russischer truppen
schüsse fallen der neue alltag in den
kurdischen gebieten syriens
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das fast ausgestorbene dorf mosa lan ist
zwischen die fronten geraten
russische und amerikanische soldaten
liefern sich absurde verfolgungsjagten
wie diese aufnahmen der dorfbewohner
zeigen die russen nutzen den weg durch
masern als abkürzung zu einem
strategisch wichtigen grenzübergang
seitdem patrouillieren gepanzerte
amerikanische fahrzeuge durch die
straßen im oktober 2009 10 marschiert
die türkische armee die nordsyrien ein
operationen quelle des friedens an der
seite der türken kämpfen auch
verschiedene islamistische milizen
ebenso wird der türkei vorgeworfen
ehemalige es terroristen zu rekrutieren
um gegen die kurdischen volkes
verteidigungs einheiten vorzugehen
für die menschen in rosa war ist die
zukunft so unsicher wie noch nie
[Musik]